all right so now we get to the end to
the sort of closing curtain of our
discussion of this absolutely pathetic
embarrassing ill-advised failed rally
that Donald Trump insisted on holding in
Tulsa Oklahoma Donald Trump was
completely furious outraged over the
large swathes of empty seats and he
flipped out on his own staff backstage
on Saturday he was completely triggered
and this might shock you
Trump blamed everybody but himself for
the failure so we already discussed what
Trump said at the rally including 20
minutes of material about walking down a
ramp and drinking water also admitted
that he tried to slow down coronavirus
testing we also saw interviews with
rally goers and the horrors that it
means about America we saw Trump
flunkies fall apart when asked about the
lack of crowds on TV so now it's about
Trump and his reaction according to
people close to the White House Donald
Trump was furious behind the scenes
about the small rally crowd before the
rally even started six of Donald Trump's
ground team had already tested positive
for coronavirus that was the start of
Trump being furious Trump mad that it
got out that six of his staff got the
virus he wanted that information
suppressed then Trump had said he
expected 22,000 people in the arena
40,000 more and overflow expecting more
than 60,000 people ended up with 6,200
and Donald Trump became completely
unhinged and furious with his own
campaign manager Brad Parr scale
reportedly Trump's family including
Ivanka also furious with Brad Parr scale
one outside adviser said quote this was
a major failure
they tried lying about why the turnout
was small offering up a lot of
protesters scared off rally goers it was
too hot the liberal media scared people
about coronavirus then they tried lying
about the crowd claiming it was 12,000
but the fire department says now it was
6,200 people but the constant thread
throughout all of this is Trump was
losing his mind before and after the
rally there's a New York Times report
which explains
that quote the president who had been
warned aboard Air Force One that the
crowds at the arena were smaller than
expected was stunned and he yelled at
aides backstage while looking at endless
rows of empty blue seats in the upper
bowl of the stadium according to four
people familiar with what took place
Brad Parr scale the campaign manager who
had put the event together was not
present so the thinnest skinned
president that we've maybe ever had is
furious again and with everybody around
him but I don't want to miss this
opportunity to refresh what is maybe a
more important conversation
whatever the reason for the failed
turnout a problem they are up against is
that they have no coherent message for
why Trump should be reelected there are
reports including that there are growing
concerns among the Trump campaign
officials that Trump neither Trump nor
his team have a coherent message for why
he should be given a second term hijinks
and triggering aside the rally was
notable for the lack of actual campaign
policy message it was look at me I can
drink water coronavirus is overblown Joe
Biden is bad
2016 was filled with promises he was
obviously not going to keep but at least
there were promises I'll build the wall
will repeal and replace Obamacare will
fix trade none of it happened and now
there's just nothing he can't really run
again on build the wall right I mean
that would just expose that he failed to
do it during his first term which is
what he had promised to do can he again
run on replacing Obamacare the plan he
proposed last time was terribly
unpopular and he's probably not going to
have the House of Representatives he may
not have the Senate remains to be seen
so what is the case for a second term
everything's terrible tomorrow on the
show we're going to talk about a new
poll where Americans are saying this is
the worst moment in American history how
do you justify your reelection Trump
being furious is of course about the
rally itself but there's a bigger
problem here which is what is the
argument to get yourself
reelected if you watch the rally Eric
Trump did a bit of a warm-up speech
which was insane and he brought up the
war on Christmas
that is something Trump talked about
four years ago I guess we supposedly won
the war on Christmas because Trump is
president but is that going to resonate
with anybody when we've got a hundred
year pandemic going to be hopefully not
but in the direction of two hundred
thousand deaths in the US by the time of
the election historically high
unemployment like is talking about the
war on Christmas going to work so we're
gonna devote more time to this tomorrow
what is the case Trump is making for his
own reelection even aides are worried
that there is really no coherent case
being made more on that tomorrow this
episode is sponsored by blue Chu one of
the things I make a priority on the show
is not to perpetuate stigma for things
that don't deserve it we've talked about
mental health we've talked about many
things where we should all just be
respectful adults period and we would be
better off and blue two can increase
performance and give you that extra
confidence you may be looking for blue
to calm blue like the color blue is the
first chewable with the same
fda-approved ingredient as in Viagra and
Cialis it can be taken day or night even
on a full stomach since it's chewable it
works twice as fast as a pill whenever
the opportunity arises blue chew is
prescribed online by licensed doctors
you don't have to go to a doctor's
office you don't have to wait in line at
a pharmacy it ships right to your door
in a discreet package they're made in
the USA and since blue two prepares and
ships direct it's cheaper than a
pharmacy and best of all no more
awkwardness we've got a special deal for
our viewers and listeners go to blue to
calm get your first shipment free when
you use our promo code Pakman that's PA
que ma n pages $5 shipping that's blue2
dot-com promo code Pakman to try it
totally free blue chew is the better
cheaper faster choice and we thank them
for sponsoring the David Pakman show